[Musique]
bienvenue à tous nous commençons avec un
exercice si jamais j'étais premier
ministre
viard tu commences là d'où je viens tout
le monde est le bienvenu
quelles que soient ses origines ou sa
nationalité et si j'étais élu premier
ministre c'est la première chose que je
défendrai nouvelle de dernière minute
une énorme explosion vient de retentir
en plein centre-ville
en attendant qu'on en sache un peu plus
toutes nos activités sont suspendues
d'accord bonjour police d'oslo vous êtes
au courant pour l'explosion oui on m'a
envoyé pour sécuriser lille
excuse moi je pourrais voir votre carte
oui bien sûr
c'était quoi ça faustine à guillet il
s'agirait de deux attaques coordonnées
la menace d'attentats et à son livre le
plus haut
ou un milliard il ya eu de graves
manquements dans le système et nous
devons savoir lesquels
c'est le seul moyen de surmonter cette
épreuve je veux lui faire comprendre ce
qu'il a fait je vais être plus fort que
lui c'est peut-être l'occasion l'homme
qu'ils ont arrêtés il veut que je le
représente
pourquoi toi je dois poser des questions
à certains témoins ce n'est pas le
procès de la norvège
c'est le vôtre vous en êtes bien sûr
je veux pas avoir l'air faible pas
devant lui
tu peux être faible et fort à la fois je
le sais ça
j'ai encore la chance d'avoir de
l'espoir
les rêves
une famille
des amis
j'ai choisi de vivre
regarde-moi on va s'en sortir témoin
confiance